chair well good evening and welcome
members officers and those members of
the public that are here at the meeting
and those joining us
vir item one apologies for
absence thank you chair apologies
received from counselors chrisy P hits L
and
Thomas but I just make you can see we've
got a new layout in the room this
evening it's a bit of a trial don't
quite know how it's going to work out
but could I ask those of you that are
speaking to speak clearly a little bit
louder than would normally does that
apply to me
sh item
two the council minutes of 30th of
October there's nothing coming out the
speaker is that any
better yeah I can't hear it
myself it is
working I can't
it is that any better
no I'll take my own advice and speak
L okay this is the minutes of the 30th
October I'll run through them page page
starting on page five
12 and
13 to move those
minutes
yes harded seconded C Le
mov you got that
right right can have sh hands all in
favor
please
against and
extensions yes 264 and four extensions
you item three on the agenda is the
action list which is PES 14 and 15 your
agenda you see there
the letter Parish G to request help
identify suitable
[Applause]
land C
haes regarding second item Southwest
water I'm sure councelor Christie was
here he would have asked about the uh
progress on this particular
matter can you tell us please well
further down the agenda uh I believe
South breest water are going to come to
the full pencil and give a presentation
we will be at that meeting will'll be
able to give them the grilling that they
probably
deserve yeah chair to confirm they'll be
coming in January thank
you item four public contributions we've
got one public speaker Mr Robert Durant
can I ask you Mr dant come up to the
microphone here thank you and you have
your three minutes when you um you start
speaking
ladies and gentlemen not long ago you
voted to prohibit fireworks displays
canelone Land close to B bridge to
avoids distress and time to the Starling
Roost there Birds which are in dangered
protected and in steep decline it is sad
and disturbing therefore that this year
a high-profile local businessman should
have made a determined effort to take
advantage of the changed ownership of
brunsick War
to reinstate just such display that you
condemn fortunately once the new site
owner became aware of the background he
very responsibly withdrew his support
and his consent to such use of
his however whilst the thed instigator
now intends to relocate his fireworks to
Westwood home for this year he seems
determined to overthrow the
effectiveness of the measures to protect
starlings and is already alluded to his
intention to try again in 2024 with
something very
similar in this unhappy context I urge
you strongly to support councelor
Hayes's motion and also to make a public
Declaration of your vement disapproval
of those and all such activities as are
likely to cause environmental harm we've
lost so
much as I was growing up in bidford we
often watch salmon being netted at just
up stream the bridge I spent countless
ining hours at the pond next to The BJs
now a grim polluted place in permanent
shade but then full of wildli fishes
frogs mutes dragonflies dancing in the
sunlight even swimming grass sakes the
streams were abundant in sticklebacks I
caught lizards and sloww worms all along
the banks of scratchy face laying near
Badger Hill beneath Hedges busy with
such birds as yellow hand
at night huge moths and beetles banged
around our ceiling lights and splattered
on the wind screen on night drives and
Barn hours often floated through the
headlight rooms hedgehogs snuffled on
our Lawns at Pines Lane every summer
night the current High View play area
was then a field of wild grasses and
abundant flowers alive with bees
butterflies and grasshoppers red
squirrels skipping through the woods who
met where Morton Park is State now is
the fields around this building were
bright with poppies our environment Is
tragically and pitously
impoverished Gage has recently begun on
some small steps to C of the trend and I
urge you to throw all your ways to find
whatever more can yet be done and to
strive to reverse such losses meanwhile
please lay down one small marker of
intent by supporting councelor Hayes's
motion
thank you thank
you
minutes moving on to item five
Declarations of Interest well you all
know the score there if you have any
interest please compare them the appro
at
time item six agreement between agenda
items part one and two Arnold part two
this evening item seven consider
correspondence any other business that's
stry brought forward by the chair I have
in
particular so moving on item eight is to
receive a verbal update from Barbara
Shaw chief executive
of don't have
to so um well thank you very much for
inviting me here with a colleague w s
who is our executive director for propy
and
um so West Housing actually employs 79
people in toy and that can be broken
down into we have 13 housing and
administrative roles eight conservative
roles and 39 people who work in our
direct labor board and that all adds to
the economic viability
and um many of us now work at home um
and that's through the technology that
we use is able to connect us as an
organization just move slide on please
so in to um we actually have just under
2,000 homes and we actually have around
s and half thousand homes across our
area of operation the majority of these
homes are General needs and just around,
1500 they've got some affordable rents
under 100 housing for older people just
over 200 homes and we've got 74 shares
on hes and those are homes that people
have bought or depart bought they own
part of the
we you like to move on the slide four
so in delivering our services we think
it's really important that we hear our
customers we listen to them we co-create
with them and we improve our services
through working with our
custom
um it's also become part of key
regulation now in terms of Housing and
that's because you would all know about
the terrible tragedy that happened in
London in 2017 with gr Tower more
recently I think over the last 18 months
you'll have seen concerns on TV
around so involving our customers is
really important we have a number of
ways that customers can get involved the
highest level of involvement for us is
customer scrutiny most people do reviews
of our services which have included
voids repairs uh D mold and tenant
services is um
IND our voice is where people can dip
dip in and dip out engagement some of
that is around surveys and some of it is
around Focus we have estate Champions
who look after estate for us and tell on
things are going WR and we also do a
state walkout where our housing officers
and property people will go out um we
will tell our customers when we go in
and walk about our St we just employed
three customer Le coordinators and again
these people will be working on the
ground with our customers and Food
Services we do independent surveys every
month with 200 of our customers who have
beened our services see what um they're
actually thinking we have a containt
service and the things we're really
looking for there is to learn from those
containts and you will know that we have
Advocates like yourself and who talk to
us on
of their
constituent of operational lead for
customer insight and engagement is just
here so if we could just move
on so I you some that so our overall
satisfaction in the Tage area is just
under
76% repairs are
81% satisfaction with inquiries 18 how
are you feel difficult to deal with 7%
and how much do you trust West I think
this one's really important' got a 7%
confidence there um and since September
we've had 18 complaints from from our
customers on tge and those have all been
resolved at St and
have like to move
on so um again you will all know about
the cost of living FES this has been
really challenging for everybody um
especially are customers and we've done
a number of things the first one is our
Westwood assurance and this means that
nobody will lose their home as long as
they speak to us we all understand that
it can be really difficult to talk to us
tell us what your problems are and we
will ensure that you maintain your home
we created a household support fund I
have to thank councelor Dame and Steve
because at first we thought this the
hardship fund and they pointed out to me
that that's probably a bit negative so
we change it to household support and we
have the employee for financial
inclusion officers and these people will
help people at the beginning of their
tency and we look at their finances to
check that they can they afford their
home also are they claiming all the
benefits they that they actually can do
we do lots of awareness campaigns which
are really important but we make sure
that we don't inundate people because
again people if they are INB seen it in
from and our customers boy group have
had input into all of our activities
with the cost of living we're also quite
a small organization in terms of housing
we do a lot of fine posting to other
organizations that can help again up
until September we've help 85 customers
in the for and that was with a total of
5,000 com wor of um financial support I
with through my um
my part of the presentation hand over to
now hello thank you hopefully you can
all hear me as well um please say if you
can't so I cover the property and
development aspect for Westwood and I'm
here to give you a little bit of of
information and background on on what
we're doing there so just
slide see what's on this screen and in
that screen so um our Property Services
team um have done numerous Investments
some big figures in there and a large
number of repairs and Home Improvements
um across there so breaking that down
into a little more detail for the year
2223 um interestingly we've done
cyclical painting on 149 homes we've
done bathroom and wet room Replacements
at are further 49 homes uh we've done
external repairs and maintenance on 187
homes we've replaced 60 heating systems
and we've replaced 71 kitchens and 55
roofs so that's a significant number
there windows and door Replacements have
been a large program for 155 homes and
that brings you to the total of 826 Home
Improvements across our stock in the
torage area so next slide
is um on a health and safety perspective
it's very is imperative for us so not
only is it regulatory there are other um
aspects to that to make sure we're
running a a um a safe organization so
from compliance perspective that covers
gas safety checks uh fire risk
assessments um lift operations Etc and
to give you an idea of our performance
on all of those so won't run through
them all with you but we are at 100%
performance on all of those with the
best off checks being um now is actually
at 98% so that's gone up from the 95%
that was was the snapshot at the moment
that slide was taken so all the other
compl matters are at 100% across our
stock which we're very pleased with it's
incredibly important to us that we that
we monitor that and our teams monitor
their kpis on a weekly basis to make
sure that they're always Meeting those
those Target figures I have the next
slide please from new development of
homes um we have in um since 2020
delivered 54 new homes for rent and
shared ownership within torid what you
see there is Homes at Philly and parkham
so we we develop in rural as well as
urban areas so um parkam was literally
three homes very small one for rent two
for shared ownership but they were
section 106 um properties but equally we
do our own build and if you know bford
we did newon Road in bford which was 31
flats and houses for a mixture of rent
and for shared ownership um and so in
total we've got 54 homes there we have
pipeline schemes but nothing that I've
got that's in contract that I been saes
you tonight but we're always working on
our pipeline as well um so could I have
the next slide please um this was a
customer satisfaction award we're very
proud of this we picked this up um I
think it's two weeks ago now so we
Benchmark our performance on new homes
build with other registered providers in
the southwest Peninsula and every year
we have a customer um conference so the
Southwest residents conference and we
compare our statistics so when a home
comes out of the defect period 12 months
after it's been built we survey the
residents and see how they found it so
we're looking for things like the
quality of the build their experience of
that moving into their new home are
there any design issues that they want
to tell us about what worked what didn't
work and we feed that back into our
process through our um design appra
panels before we do any new developments
and we're particularly proud of this one
because we got the customer satisfaction
award um for our prison Place
development which is literally down the
road from here it was done with NG
properties we took section 106
properties and some additional
properties from them for rent and
shareed ownership and the picture to the
right hand side was um when those those
houses were newly developed and they've
been moved into and we actually had H
England come down and Steve I think you
were present on today as well and we
walk around and had a look at the
properties that that were completed it's
been a very good successful scheme for
us and we're really proud to to have got
that satisfaction award because that
comes from the residents feedback and
the survey so we're really pleased with
that one
and the final
slide excuse me a picture there of echo
in Brown Court newly decorated and
there's our compliance manager stood
with residents um in the living room
there the land so if there are any
questions um we' be happy to take
them back thank you chair but you like
to ask me about um cl to are you with
the oldest hot hous and starting
reducing carbon emissions energy saving
things about that well we have um
recently been successful in securing
some wave two funding I don't know if
you've come across wave two funding it's
central government grant funding which
we have to match with our own Financial
contribution and that's about
retrofitting some of our older
properties and getting those epcs the
energy performance certificates up to
the SE or better so we have a program of
investment to achieve that we've just
developed our own in-house um EPC tool
as we call it so there are commercial
varieties available our own it team have
developed one for us so we can actually
track as a kpi the performance of our
over stock and we have um an
environmental working group internally
which puts forward our environmental
strategy so where we need to invest Etc
so we're doing quite a lot of work
quietly on
that see at
the so we
205 thank you very much BR yes sir um
right to buy the impact that's had on
Housing Association or west in
particular and uh what's happened to the
receipts from that and are you getting a
reasonable settlement from well use the
word carefully settlement from central
government to increase the stock of
housing it's very but because the only
of the white F were up in college when
we first did the stock transfer I
couldn't give you the detail Council
them but we can certainly find out but
actually it slowed down considerably um
in my time I've been at Westwood for 12
years um I you know it isn't something
that is significant on our agend I think
all the people that
put like it Bigg as if I could
P Mr
gy yeah I just wanted to ask how easy uh
you're finding it to access access homes
England funding uh because I was
recently at a meeting with a John Hart
um who was talking about Devon's
strategy and he was complaining about
the amount of money that homes England
had returned uh to the the exer because
many housing associations and housing
authorities in Devon hadn't been able to
access funding through it I wonder what
your experience is um I don't think
you've got accessing funding it's about
everything that makes up um what we need
to do in terms of making a being viable
so I think you know we like everyone
else have suffered through cost of
living our interest rates on all of our
loans have gone up um after covid all of
the costs on building went up and we
have other priorities I mean um we're a
small organization but actually the cost
for our maintenance bills have gone up
significantly by millions um so you're
having to balance with these things and
what we have to remember one of the
things that West board members would St
is is we are a landlord first a
developer second um there if that is
your priority then you will obviously
when the going gets tough you reduce
your development program that is being
seen across the country the consequence
is that H dland is not being spent those
are the hard realities I think there are
other mechanics which Rachel might want
to come in on but that is the politics
at the moment you know there are a
combination of factors that mean that
actually we can't develop the we would
like
to I
to thank you chair um Community Land
trusts quite often have a good handle on
what communities need um from a housing
perspective has Westward had any
involvement with Community Land trusts
and would you consider that um we
haven't in recent years had involvement
in F other
than tangent of supporting another local
Authority in um in going through sort of
a financial approval process for them
and supporting them in doing so so we
don't directly we haven't got any direct
involvement with the CLT at
present ccor h
j um thanks very much for presentation
I'm pleased that um you have very good
customer relations um I'm not so sure
you have such good relationships with
people like myself a counselor s of
seeking information as my experience is
or one particular case for example it's
a listed building in square in Northern
the old schoolhouse which I think is
owned by West
Housing um I waited weeks and weeks for
a response from you about the condition
of it um on other queries if I do get a
response it tends to be an encrypted
email which is very hard to actually um
plunet um in order to find out what the
response is um so I I would hope that
maybe you can improve that communication
system also I'd like to ask as an appor
counselor um Top Field of tooth in
appledore I was ass short by one of your
managers a few years ago that will be
developed or inhance diversity um I
don't think that's happen so I just
wonder if you could answer that as well
thank you well first can I apologize if
quar I don't
know but I'm sure that you can get my
email the um Steve or counselor James
and I will be more than happy to answer
questions and the incription egest um I
think that's very easy to solve we have
to put lots of things into incription as
you call it beond um but there are ways
Le that
absolutely I'm not quite sure about that
one I'm afraid I'm not you with but if
you pass me the
details around get whole Top Field it's
um a community um community area of land
and it's owned by West Housing and it's
at the end of to so perhaps youd even
that as to the encryption I've not met
any other case with any other
organization where you have an encrypted
email I would have to stay know in
because with certain information it does
have but it e
Sol thank you
chair yeah I've had a number of
complaints come to me over the years
concerning biomass boilers and in one
case it was only resolved when BBC
Spotlight got involved and these
complaints have been going on for many
many
months I'd I'd like to ask firstly what
is the situation with biomass boilers in
your properties at the
moment and secondly a number of the
older properties had chimneys which
allowed for wood
burners and the wood burners had to be
taken out and in some cases the chimney
removed now if you have a problem with
combustion I'm sure that you can have
the necessary alarms put in
and if it's a concern over the flu you
can have them regularly swept as part of
a maintenance contract to ensure that um
it's
compliant many of the people living in
these
properties are on low
incomes and every penny pants and with
Village locations firewood is very often
freely available so I would like your
comments on that and would it be
possible to reverse this policy thank
you I the biomas yes biomas was an
initiative a green initiative which we
did get government money for but I would
confer it was um not successful for all
sorts of reasons and the pellets were um
a disaster but we have replaced all of
those biomasses that we' wanted Place
some people wanted to keep them because
actually um in a time of living prices
they were cheaper it's cheaper by the
pellets and was by the um by
oer um we haven't had any complaints
about biom I would say for the last 12
months but if you if you know somebody
who is concerned let me know and we will
try to solve that the have that the um
the stoves and firewood are a bit more
complicated yes so from that perspective
I understand where you're coming from in
rural communities but with um wood
burning stoves and chimneys that's the
first thing on an EPC certificate that
will blow us out of the water
unfortunately so um it's a really
negative factor when you're having an
EPC measurement done on the property um
and it's the the one thing that we we
need to avoid I don't see that we could
get to an EPCC with B burning stones and
chimneys sorry it's um it's just one of
those things we have to face I just come
back on that because I don't believe
that to be
true I I I think my property which is
heated by wood burners has the SE
certificate because I've got solar
panels in the
root chair I just also come back on that
please because we just completed a house
two years ago and that's pass all the
building RS and we've got wood burning
Stone and that's our main heating thing
and and electric FL heating as well but
that's but the the stove pass that was
proved by building control I don't
understand this that might also link the
fabric first approach so modern building
High Energy Efficiency fabric you could
probably offset that however if we're
talking about some of old the properties
in rural areas maybe that's that's the
combination of the two is why it doesn't
work what we can do is we come back to
on that I mean obviously you don't feel
that what was saying is appropriate so
we will get some more advice on that and
I give
you one one last point my Cottage is
over 300 years old so IID don't be an
age thing but you're also taking out the
chimney so that it's not possible to
retrofit in a number of cases so really
the stable door is being
boled after the horse has left oh thank
you for that but we will come back to
your
Mar yeah thank you uh ladies thank you
for your presentation you inevitably
understandably perhaps uh showcased the
the the good the modern the new uh
likewise your statistics that you
produced were where you were doing well
um perhaps if uh you were uh speaking to
the external oversight and scrutiny
committee uh there could be more context
put where we could look and scrutinize
more on other things which inevitably
perhaps aren't going quite so well but
you chose not to mention here I have a
plea for you and that is showcasing the
modern stuff the good stuff is
easy um I'm down in winley in the in in
in in the bottom of the the patch and I
have like most other counselors I have a
traditional old counselor State can I
ask that actually
75% of your attention and effort is
actually diverted at the Old Stock and
not the new the new is easy and it's
easy to apply to it's the old where we
actually need the attention because the
the social context of the old is quite
different from what we build in the new
now and I have a former counselor State
yours now mainly yours pepper potted
with with ones which have been bought
but dividing fences don't exist it it
looks T back um and actually effort that
put on it from a context to say how can
we really lift this um would make a huge
amount of difference and I just get the
impression that all the all the effort
is look what we're doing new buildings
not that many of them actually compared
to your overall stock new aren't we
doing well and look at these figures
actually go look at the majority of your
stock in some of our patches and the
reality is not that good better I would
suggest we spend 60 million on our
existing potis if you look at E Brown
that is not a new scheme that is a
scheme that has beened and it's had new
faes of paintless and I think it looks
new but actually it's not new I take on
board what you said about lley um and we
have a look I can't redirect all of our
resources there though like others not
I'm not pleas I'm not making it be on
particular water there are those type of
Estates one sees all over so don't don't
think that I'm making a plea
particularly for my B but just as a
common thing the older stock requires
more human effort to actually overcome
the fact that it's you know I think
previous coun Point wasn't it about home
England and the reason that housing
associations aren't taking up that Grant
anymore is because we have recognized
that we need to focus on our
existence actually you a bit say you're
going to be the last speaker but before
I can finish the sentence L put a hand
up you will be the last speaker right
thank you chairman um I think I'm not
guilty considering that you've made so
much investment and in some ways moved
so so much further um since I the dra on
is cancel but I just want to take you
back a little while to when you need to
do invest in the community and you
invested in something for Gig which was
an amazing an amazing project and did an
Untold amount of good in bord for a lot
of people who are particularly advantage
and although I'm asking probably a lot
under the current CL I'm just wondering
if at any time in the future you might
be able to consider doing that again
thank you
well consider it I think it's quite hard
it may come back in a different format
um that's why we're employing three
coordinators well it
is I mean you know we were all very them
but in terms of their
liability and
[Music]
exem I just ask um has been quite a lot
to talk about the old What proportion of
your stock falls into an old category
rather than the new build type yeah
proportionately and also the damp and
mold problems are they a feature of duly
the old stock is the new stock um not
have those problems they being resolved
or a question
ofation and problem
AR
so so we've have just under 2,000 homes
in poge and I think Rachel did say that
we have built 54 homes that for um
since so you know the proportion of new
homes is is quite small um the J M issue
can affect both homes the problem with
new homes is they are so firmly
efficient they cannot
bre so consequently can get down for
more if can get down for more because
render hasn't dried out prop
water but I'm not saying that has been a
significant problem for us but we have
seen that in other housing associations
and and other parts country damp mold in
are existing um can be for all sorts of
reasons it can be because of the
structure of the building it's getting
old we may have watering breath it can
also be because because of people's
behavior um it depends but whatever type
of understand more people feel that they
have in their home if they tell us about
it we will go we will review it and we
will do
something well thank you ladies for that
presentation very inform thank you very
much we'll get back to the the questions
thank you very much thank
you and moving on to item nine on your
agenda is the local pens tax reduction
scheme ages 16 to 19 and Gordon
Bryant officer will
present yeah thank you chair so the
report describes the local operation of
P's council tax reduction SCH it covers
those of working age there are separate
Arrangements in place for pensioners and
is also separate those St deductions
that are in place such as related to
single person dis
the report recommends are not lifting
the thresholds by which the reductions
are applied this will increase the
support we offer to those on Modest
incomes and the cost of the cage is
detailed on the following page on page
18 so it be
,000 a year that that it will cost us
doing summary therefore share this an
increase to the thresholds bring them
more into line with comparable um local
councils cre supports on
offer
question I move
recommendation
second GRE second all in favor please
show any
against on any
[Music]
exensions moving on to item 10 Again
council tax base 24 25 Pages 20 to
23 yeah thank you chair so on page 20 is
the draft of the council tax base and
the addendum to the paper has the final
number that you're recommending to you
as the council tax base for next year
now this is an important step to been
able to set a council tax for next year
and and and to be able to set a revenue
for bit also for next
year next year's Council ta base has
been arrived at after looking at new
property builds and assumptions over
collection rates and supports that will
be
on the tax Bas is shown I found the
equivalence and I've taken off a
percentage for
non-collection once agreed by the
council this information is then passed
on to other preceptors who can then able
to set their budgets and set their
council tax on the basis of it this is
eventally a technical paper rather than
an issue of principal policy for
coun any comment I'm looking for a
proposal second all in favor
please thank
you thank
you so moving on to item 11 licensing
act policy review Pages 24 to
56 we're going to receive a report need
LIC par thank
you yes the purpose of the report is to
seek approval for the adoption of the
authorities rised statement of Licensing
policy is a requirement of Licensing act
for each licensing authority to
determine such a policy the policy must
be reviewed every five years and the
current policy will expire in January
2024 um the PR's policy of Ino
consultation process it's also been
approved by the licensing committee this
was done on the 18th of October
2023 and a recommendation from the
licensing committee to the full Council
was for full adoption of the
policy thank you chair yeah I'd like to
propose that we approve the statement of
Licensing policy I believe this policy
will be key in continuing to deliver the
key licensing objectives which is
preventing crime disorder ensuring
Public Safety prevention of public
nuisance and to protect children from
harm uh and with the support of the
Emergency Services I'm confident that we
will keep our community safe thank
you thank you all favor please
show than in
second okay I'm
gu any
extensions is there any point to put my
hand up because you did you didn't take
any notice of I had a point of
information I do apologize Brenton I
didn't see your hand go no I put my hand
up you did yeah I've
saying she wanted to speak before the
vote no I don't want to speak
I information about the alcohol
excluding I was just ignored I didn't
wasn't ignoring you counc I just didn't
see you well I have got a red code just
stay shair with your hand up and I I W
miss you in the
future so is that you
[Music]
depending on this result of my
question well Tak a v on it now
still
obiously one exstension
then moving on to item 12 purchas of
tractor Pages 57 to 63 and Cory has
present
report thank you chair um the The Point
View contains a recommendation for
Community Resources commity
to increase the C program by the some
55,000 LS for the purchase of a compact
tractor funded by the higher level
stewardship scheme which we apply for
for the Burrows every year so this is a
request that's come to us from the B
service and the grain maintenance
service uh put together um the practor
will do our hat management work and it
will also do management Tri side down so
very briefly uh the recommendation is to
increase the tax program by
55,000
thank any
comments can I just ask I'm
sorry I just wonder what it by it would
be a
decent we looked at umic one battery
card one sorry and there wasn't one
suitable and affordable so unfortun you
come to this conclusion on this
speci um may I ask have alternative fuel
these fruit F hydrogenized vegetable
room nowadays I be quite interested in
having that looked into for all of our
diesel um vehicles within anual because
our carbon footprint is that falling and
I understand that we can't afford
electric vehicles are not available
suitable because of our Ral environment
but um the hydrogenized um vegetable
which is available in souw and could
actually possibly used for all of our
vehicles really it's not bodal it's
different
I details that but I'd like to ask
consider yeah so I spoke briefly with
the uh the head of sorry the operation
services manager the for meeting he he
did mention that that was a a less
preferable option but I'm I'm certain
that if you've got information that
you'd like to uh talk to us about after
the meeting if we get approv to purchase
this we can see whether that's an
option C P I believe you have your hand
up thank you chair I just want to ask
councelor Hicks I believe voted against
at CNR and yet he's now recommending
that you person can you explain or have
I got that information
yeah I had
[Music]
aat I'm
sorry thank
you mention funding was coming from high
level Steward 100% funding or yes chair
uh we we receive about 33,000 a year
through the F scheme currently carrying
a balance of £70,000 on that so the
funding would be 100% from that
scheme counc hes thank yeah just follow
up and councilor Lille um I understand
that Richard haste and uh Donna siy
joint climate officer are always very
much aware of alternative fuels and they
are actually looking at the use of
arated vegetable it's a possibility
thank you idea okay it's been proposed
canone sorry
propos James second from the chair all
in favor please
show
against the
exensions four than you
sure so moving in to item 13 proposed
withdrawal and dissolution of part of
the S West joint committee Pages 64 to
68 Steve was going to present the rep uh
thank you chair um so I guess many
members been around since the the part
the Southwest joint committee it was
back in
2015 it was brought in uh when
government policies around local
Enterprise R
Partnerships um and it was seen as the
the vehicle to engage the partnership
district councils and other partners
with the the local Enterprise
partnership now the the government
policy has changed local Enterprise
Partnerships will be uh rolled into
unitary authorities or where there's
Devolution deals or County deals rolled
into those arrangements from next April
so there's no longer a requirement to
have a joint committee um um but because
the the way the Constitution sits it has
still has to be uh voted from the
constituent authorities to the
arrangement so chair that's the
recommendation on the paper is seing
thank Steve counc
Brendon thank you chair I remember when
this came in I thought this was um the
next best thing to slice bread you know
was going to save us all investment blah
blah blah sort of leveling up part one I
think it was it seems that way anyhow
well OB
it's all it because these authorities
aren't turning out by they voted with
their feet so it hasn't worked just a
waste of money and it's just a you know
yet another sort of gimmick if you like
on giving the illusion that we have
somehow some control or some input into
central government no we don't so yes of
course you got to disolve it and all
that money will be distributed iect
we'll get a few quit of it but not much
propose it I propose that we actually
dissolve it yes
thank
you the speakers has been proposed by
counc Brenton sorry counc Jes you
proposed it did you counc proposed it
can I a second James second all in favor
please
show thank
you item 14 a draft strategic plan for
2024 29 AG 69
109 thanks thanks again chair so uh
following um a number of workshops uh
you've we' HED with uh counselors uh
starting back in August of this year um
so this draft strategic plan is
following the the consultation process
that took place over the a number of
weeks prior to this evening uh so back
in August we had the first Workshop from
that Workshop
a number of themed group meetings with
lead members and officers uh then we
brought to your attention a draft plan
uh to submit and put out to to
consultation so the consultation now
closed it was extended uh by a week uh
to engage more widely with parish and
town councils because some of some of
the information hadn't got through to to
the rant uh counselors we've had a much
better response this to this strategic
plan than we've had previous plans we've
also had a much greater involvement and
engagement with members in this plan and
if you recall 30 or2 36 members um
attended that first
Workshop um so we've captured all the
information all the consultation
comments in the report I see first part
reduct the names as you'd expect uh so
we've had 93 responses in total which I
think was 30% uh from last time so a
relatively good uh level of Engagement
you'll see on page 70 uh the two
highest in relation to housing and the b
b reate the B ADV rail rail line um in
terms of the the housing comment
obviously we the intention was they
would all be encapsulated within the
council's housing strategy when that's
developed so whil there were lots of
different comments around different
levels of detail the expectation is that
will be cared within that housing
strategy in terms of the uh reopening of
the b b Railway is that we've included
that in the uh report um and you'll see
that the intention is to engage with
Partners OB see there's going be a short
uh stretch of the former real Link in
the B good area we need to engage and
investigate with relevant Partners uh
North Bon Council Deon County Council
and some of the the rail bodies uh to to
see and establish whether there's any
trate to commission a study uh to
determine whether um the feasibility the
impacts environmental impacts economic
impacts uh suggest that that should be
taken forward to to that next stage um
chair in relation to the comments
they've all been
grouped um in line with the themes um to
try and explain to those respondents
where they've been dealt uh where and
how they've been dealt with in the final
documentation Ching going through those
there quite a number of pages and over
see what this would have gone through
and read that chair I think the uh
leader just wants to say a few
words thank you Chief SEC um as he said
as St said that um we have much more
positive response all the way through
this time we used to have workshops col
of do we thought we're doing quite well
this time we did get 30 um I extended it
by week all my Parish councilors saying
please respond to emails that the counil
sent and when we looked at the list a
lot of them didn't even open the emails
that come from college so I didn't' got
major exercise to do there um but I that
we I what recomendation was we adopt it
the final
um thing and the one thing I would say
is that this will give us a little bit
of a a guidance when we come to looking
IT projects within the leveling up
partnership it won't necessarily be what
go through the system but it's what we
will be looking at of what we want there
is an element we will have to manage is
what we want to what actually fits the
criteria but by using the strategy we
can actually say this is what we will be
driving colge forward so as I said I
don't believe the recommendation adopt
it Mr brenon thank you chair well I'm
intrigued that um you see the fact that
there were more responses as a very
positive aspect having waited through
the comments there's many of them that
are really quite negative there's a lot
of criticism for the fact that it's too
vague um words like read purp in the
Town Center whatever that means um
clearly you may have got a lot of
responses but that doesn't mean to say
they were successful responses because
from these comments people either didn't
understand what you were going to do and
I wonder who does and um or that it's so
vague that again it's like motherhood
and apple pie nobody's going to vote
against it of course they're not but it
doesn't have any actions in it there's
lots of comments about the the fact that
there's nothing specific there's no
actual plan some somebody here says this
isn't a plan because there's no targeted
achievable things that we can measure
that's what a plan is well when I was
doing sociology um so you know the idea
that this is a great response you know
I'm afraid I must disagree and I feel
that you know when we had our strategy
meeting there was a you know I found
then that it was too vague and this just
reiterates that it confirms that this is
so vague that nobody's going to complain
about it but they're not really
convinced that we're going to do any
good for our community
either sh I I respond um yes obviously
we're not going to please every
everybody with the information we we put
out and the when we have
consultations um it is uh meant to be uh
vague in in some table form because is
at the the highest level it is a
strategic document the the intention as
outlined previously is that will be
broken down and each of your service
areas across the council will build and
develop operational plans which provide
a lot more detail Target dates for
completion different projects different
pieces of work and then that forms the
basis of the council's service plans
going forward uh they progress against
those are reported to your internal
overview and scrutiny committee on a
quely basis then that provides the
challenge back to officers on on what's
been achieved or not in terms of the
comments of the repurposing uh of towns
that was addressed and has been changed
in the final document now is
revitalizing and repurposing in ter
centers to meet their changing needs so
when that part of the consultation come
back me Members lead members where they
met and I decided to make that
change three speakers can wh was first
then councelor gregy thank you chair um
I'm I'm a bit more than mildly curious
actually we've got seven responses here
for art and culture well I know how much
interest is in in the town so how do you
embra that because I am say a bit more
than
and
honestly arts and culture arts and
culture there were seven responses and I
have read lots of
them on
fire
people that mention various things
about and I would have thought that
Heritage might just Reserve its own
stand the community's health and
housing community sosing yeah yes I
think we've indicated on the on the
document they are included in council's
um culture strategy and that's the way
they'll be dealt with
thank you
very M it was just in response to that
we had our first meeting of the northern
Devon culture board and that that will
include Heritage within that Northern de
strategy which is included in the
Strategic F thank you for that thank you
great yeah thank you very much
um basically I think after hearing what
westw housing was saying about the
developing of of housing I want to know
um why the the suggestions put forward
by through by bford Town Council but an
an action point on page 86 and the
community health and housing that the
ability to set up a way of facilitating
the building of social social housing is
not in itself a key priority given that
we've got a housing crisis going on at
the moment and we PA it from the horse's
mouth that
social landlords have to deal with their
core element of their business and that
they can't put the time into getting
those grants which we know are available
and have been returned to central
government central government is
obviously desperate to hand out the
money why as a council can we not
facilitate those housing associations
access that funding as a key strategic
aim given the importance of housing to
our area
the importance of housing in making
maintaining a strong economy in the area
and giving people hope of a future here
in the area is about how having housing
for for young people and so again I
would like to propose that we include
the suggestion from bford Town Council
that is the
action which on page 86 which is under
the community's health and housing to
set up a system for the council to to
facilitate and construct sh rented
homes a second that
dend okay it has it's dealt with as part
of the POS strategy that that intention
to look at all forms of housing as part
of that piece of
work I'll get you in a second c h two
before you oh
sorry thank you chair um I'm delighted
to see that the highest number of uh
responses to this is the the railway B
to benefit um as chair of the T Valley
Railway I constantly bleed on about the
fact that it should really be called to
Great torington uh and I think a very
nice intermediate stop in in b um we
we've already got several hundred yards
of C laad we have a a working train that
we' bought from Great West so I think
we're in a position to um to push
ourselves forward um and I I constantly
say please can we change the name from B
to thank
you
thank you um Steve you said that um
various departments will tie the
Strategic plan into their service
plans um how does that work with
planning because planning is keing to
our economy in quite a lot of um
instances and I'm not sure they would
look at our speciic plan like they do
their local plan or our local plan
and
ultimately it has to be everybody in
this C working towards that aim and I
feel that quite often there is a
blockage along the way and um and I did
promote the to
our
C and they did see fact that it was a
little
bit what you feed back to because it
it's all obvious go
against
[Music]
May so obviously planners make decisions
according to the plan and that being the
local plan rather than the council
strategic plan we're about to embark on
the journey towards a new local plan and
our strategic plan is a key evidence
document in the formulation of new
policy against which future decisions
will be made so in the short term it has
Lal impact it sets momentum it gives the
plan as a f for what the council wants
but they make the decision against the
current plan it will be key to the
future plan
okay coun haes I
believe i' like to support councelor
craigy um regarding this um his proposal
on social housing I I did suggest that
the inclusion of this when we had a a
sort of Workshop meeting and I was told
that the words provide housing for local
needs covers such things um including
social housing but it's so vitally
important and the most obvious route uh
for us to provide vital housing for
people on low incomes I think it needs
identifying and including so
support sorry CH also just to say I
thought that's that was the rout we were
taking um in this Council in terms of
identifying our own land and with a
particular emphasis on social
hous okay as I said the the hous
strategy when when we develop the terms
of reference and how he sets the scene
for that strategy that is intended to
incor all types
of that's that's the plan
already we
leave
proposition proposed that the with the
the insertion in the community's health
and housing that the fford suggested
which is on page 86 of the document that
the inclusion of set up the system for
the council to facilitate the
construction of
Socials and so I'm proposing that is
added in as an
action I believe Council friend
second
second I think I stood and um answered
this issue at the first meeting where we
were looking at this
strategy I have housing strategy has got
to consider all types of housing need we
have issues around key workers leaving
accommodation we have issues around
firsttime buyers wanting to get their
putot on the ladder and the kind of
products we could offer them self bill
was mentioned the other
day social housing is important we've
heard Tonight from One of
the registered providers they're not the
only
provider so when we put together a
housing strategy we have to take all
these strands and consider them all as
significant issues for the whole
community so to pick out a commitment to
social housing if I were a key worker
looking for a house I'd be asking this
Authority what are you doing about me
I'm providing services to your community
and I need to be housed but I don't
necessarily want to be housed in social
housing so it's our housing strategy is
the key document for us and we need to
all feed into that and I'm not disputing
the fact please don't think I'm
antisocial housing I'm so frankly it was
disgusting of you suggest that
workers
well I do take exception I don't think
it's disgusting I think social housing
is very important within our
communities so I rest my case we need to
get a robust housing strategy for this
Council we haven't got it yet and we all
need to work together to put that
together thank
you
Brenton things I think what council C is
proposing is actually to sharpen it up
to get some focus in on what we do need
in this community and you know as well
as I do German that social housing is
something that is desperately needed in
this area as for the key worker element
well I have to say and confess that was
it 45 years ago we had a hey worker
house in bford when have we had them
since then Council house a council house
at church Ro we didn't think it was
disgusting I was delighted to be there
after the rubbish substandard flap that
we lived investable so you know let's
get something right here but it is
important that we prioritize and really
prioritize what is required in our area
you see saw the statistics earlier on in
in the um the earlier one we had one
well that all statistics how poor we are
in this area God damn it we know is poor
yes we still going to have to go to
government and demonstrate that that is
the case they should know know that
already they got it all in their
archives want to look at it so that's
the reason why I supported what coun
said and we should do it let's show our
constituents that actually we do care
about the fact that we desperately need
social housing in this area and we're
not doing enough about it let the
developers get away with blue murder at
the
moment thank you and I apologize for um
talking process but if we take one item
of many priorities that we have if we
take one item and place it in our
strategic plan
column that becomes
Direction it doesn't it falls outside of
a plan now each of our particular
priority areas then have a much more
Focus thought through it all comes in
front of us here deliberated and
approved plan for that particular area
and as chair of the internal oversight
and scrutiny who are responsible for the
quarterly scrutiny of the quarterly
Business Report so the monitoring of
progress on all of this
I have to say that actually we skew the
whole system it's not saying that one
thing that it's not important but we
skew the whole system if we actually
take something which should be listed as
an operational
level uh Direction and we actually
elevate it right up into the Strategic
level overall Blue Sky Thinking um
planning level and if we do that then we
we we throw the whole system because
there's many many other parts of this
responsibility that this Council does
right away from our money all the way
through all the different areas the
local economy we know it all here all
all all as you can see it all on the the
the draft plan here and if I'm just very
worried that if we start putting
Direction too early on then it we lose
the focus required on a specific plan
for for a specific subject and we do
have a specific plan we've got the the
housing strategy that when it comes it's
going to be looked at it's going to be
looked at by my committee it'll be
looked at by CN it can be looked at by
by this committee this Council it will
get full full scrutiny but most
importantly it will be seen as a whole
where all aspects will be brought
together and looked at and Drawn
Together as an overall plan not picking
out one priority within it say we're
going to do this and everything else
doesn't actually meet that bar so I
would make a plea that I hear exactly
what people are saying and I understand
people's passion and importance but the
the process of business planning we've
got to start they they do sound rather
vague these words but they set the tempo
for the for the officers and the council
and the various committees then to to
build their particular plans and
strategies underneath them and it does
work but I I worry if we try to put too
much detail up front we then put
people's arms behind their back uh and
we're actually putting Direction Where
um wide angle planning and thinking
should
be I know
you
but you know it goes from this committee
to that committee to the other committee
to sort of just reiterate what we all
know I mean I would have thought of
really driving force to address the
problem of social housing is the money
with spending on temporary accommodation
because we hav't got any social and if
there was anything that was going to
drive this Council because it doesn't
seem to be just a need or an obvious
need and the distress of people who are
whose needs are not being met is the
cost to the council you know deal with
your social housing problem and you you
reduce your cost of putting people into
temporary
unsatisfactory housing I mean it's a
win-win and I don't know you know
everybody knows we need it everybody
keeps agreeing how many more committees
has it got to go in front of before we
say what we need to be doing
today or tomorrow is applying for Grants
or whatever it is that we get the money
it's no good saying we can't have we
haven't got the money to do this well
there's grants out there and if money is
going back to central government instead
of going into you know I don't know
buying 106 houses or whatever we need to
do to increase the stock of social
housing we need to be doing it now not
not in a plan that's a bit vague so
we'll then get the shop and up plan that
goes the next one and another six months
down the road and we'll have another
think about it and somebody else will
say We'll propose it and we'll second it
and think we need to do it now because
money is just leeching out of the
council to support the people who need
the social housing
it's I don't know it's it to me it's a
no
brainer bra your hand up this one thank
you ch thank
you um I totally agree with councelor
Lille about this whole situation and I
completely refute what councelor Newton
says because we know that we need social
housing I as far as I'm concerned it
should be our top
priority and that should be emphasized
in this plan because it needs to be
because it hasn't been solved up till
now it didn't just suddenly come on the
horizon this year it's a accumulating
situation for many years on torage and
of course in many other um communities
and we really should put our money where
our mouth is and say that we believe
that social housing is our top priority
councelor Hudson says oh that would be
unfair because we're pinpointing one
section of the community even though it
is the most needy and probably in many
ways the most
deserving because we've got all these
other people and they'll be I don't know
what quite what she Point she was making
but they apparently look a scars at that
but the fact is we have some huge
developments taking place in V we have
the nearly 800 houses from BL homes up
Beyond Atlantic Village they are already
taking place people who want to move
into this area and can afford to buy
houses are not
disadvantaged people who want to live in
this community and have been born and
bred here and have benefit from our low
wage which is one of the low lowest in
the country as we know from these
statistics we've just seen about the
leveling up they are the ones that are
disadvantaged they can't compete and buy
these expensive homes that are being
built all around us so the idea that it'
be unfair in some way to pinpoint our
dire local need for social housing is
ridiculous it's bizarre it's ignoring
reality social housing the lack of it in
our community is a huge elephant in the
room and in this room and to ignore it
is to be Tous to the extreme can I just
bring in St
before thank you chair um overall I've
got responsibility for housing within
within the council
um I run the department um councilor
Hodson is actually my um lead member for
housing and I have many a debate with
Council Hudson um in particular in
relation to producing a housing strategy
and we do have one it's out of day and
with what we want now I I agree we do
need social housing but that's not the
only thing that that we need not
everyone that we have in temporary
accommodation wants a social rented
house a lot of them want to be able to
buy a house they want to be able to get
on the property ladder some have had to
vacate rural areas because they want to
be in the village that they grew up with
so I think I've got to support what
councel Hudson said said this time if we
have strung ourselves to just social
housing in our strap plan then that is
the only thing that we will be looking
at if we have a housing strategy and
this comes through we can look at all of
these areas but I promise you I have
many discussions with many people in our
accommodation and then not all looking
to rent social housing it is a balance
and actually just just a word because
Council Hudson have been asking for me
to start preparing the housing strategy
I think a lot of this needs to come
through the planning scheme but which
I'm not an expert in and that's why
we've been discussing with with sha but
a lot of this has to be facilitated
through our planning process and our new
local
plans thank you chair well this is a
draft
strategic policy that we're looking at
and I agree with councelor
um Hudson councelor Hudson and I agree
with what state is just there can to
whip up hysteria over social housing it
get us nowhere at
all and sty took the words out of my
mouth I was going to say not everybody
who's looking for a home is looking for
a social home look at deire homes the co
man away they're building they're giving
us the full uh
range of affordable langages there's
another site of corn which will come on
stream they will be 30% of affordable
now most of the affordable 75% is for
rent in our policy but there's so many
other issues to do with housing as
councelor Hodson said this this
downsizing to elderly people who are
probably looking for bungalows in fact
goodness we are building a few more
Bungalows now fact in this was in the
bir the week the second largest
Authority with
bungalows in in the country in England
so we are building some more but that is
another issue when you read in our
strategic draft plan here and look at
the bullet point there the first bullet
point increase the availability and the
quality of homes to meet local needs and
that covers many things besides social
he and to develop and the action is to
develop and Implement a
hous that provides Creative Solutions to
meet the housing needs of the district
that said it all there and what state is
just said is the right way to go but all
this whipping up this theor about social
housing if we're all heartless and don't
care about not everybody wants social
housing there are people who who are in
temporary hous who want to buy hous and
first time is a ke issue that we should
address
thanks on the note of first time bias
Etc there comments in here about
supporting the youth within our
community and actually encouraging them
to um gain decent
experience gainful enjoyment of of
policy um rather
than the super market like and that then
knocks on and ties in with people being
able to afford reasonably T housing not
necessarily social housing um but they
are actually on the right track to
support themselves and then if we can
Implement in some form um affordable
homes within our villages in t which is
what we are really lacking
so that people can get a fo hold on the
lad as they grow and move on we've got
more that's the way that
people mental attitude is more
well but
it C I missed you C you can put your
hand down if you want I will get you
that's your PR thank you chair I I can
see the point that this is part of a
larger housing strategy and I apologize
if has been mentioned and I just didn't
pick it up earlier in the conversation
do we have a a kind of timetable for
when the housing strategy might come
first to a first committee sort of what
is there anything that you can tell us
because it's obviously something that we
all think is hugely important and so
we're just eager I sense that's why this
debate is happening now because we're
eager to put something down that said
this is a priority but if we know when
the housing strategy is is coming
forward then we can maybe get a sense
that yes this is going to be written
down and agreed on soon rather than in
the future we can't identify yeah as I
said earlier that that's the plan we
need the strategy for we need the
Strategic plan first to develop those
operational plans and that's why it
comes to you in this order you're set in
the Strategic direction of the council
and from that then we develop those
retail plans so we haven't pinpointed an
exact date or time but we recognize it's
some it's high on the
agenda can you give any indication at
all are we talking sort of a year's time
three years time when we might be able
to agree on our housing strategy try
20 one of the key points to men in there
is establishing POS in need so we need
need to understand the the need to
develop strategy from so there's a
couple of pieces of work that need to
feed collect the data the evidence to
build the strategy and that's the the
next set of that forms part of the work
of the local plan as well so they all
need to work in conjunction with each
other um I just like to say you know
thank you to council for pointing out
that all these wonderful massive housing
Estates are having a wonderful
proportion of affordable housing so the
affordable housing issue is already
being addressed great we're really
pleased to hear it and there's lots of
Estates going up 800 houses here 400
houses there and they houses in there
for these people who don't want to live
in social housing and want to get a foot
on the ladder great go for it and really
please for you where are the numbers of
social housing being built also at the
same time now as these Estates are being
built now as these Bungalows for older
people who want to downside of being
built now where are the social housing
that are being built now I know that
Sully hous has come up and that's like
eight or 11 or whatever and I was
brilliant and it looks lovely and I'm
really pleased that that happened but
where are the social housing people now
because you know the need that needs to
be addressed the bungalows social
housing whatever are coming out of these
400 600 800 houses where are the ones
now yeah so uh my view is that as
counselors it's our job to reflect point
of time the point of time we're in um I
think it's establish
that there are significant deficiencies
in housing provision perhaps and that's
why we have a housing
crisis and councelor craigy is proposing
a one of the solutions to tackling that
housing crisis so but I also understand
that this is a strategic plan and the
need to step away from operational
Solutions perhaps but when I read the
Strategic plan at the moment I don't
think it reflects the point of time we
are in
in that that paragraph could be put at
any point in time in the history of
torich in the future or in the past so
to develop an Implement a housing
strategy that provides Creative
Solutions to meet the housing needs of
the district absolutely but it does seem
to have missed the fact that at this
point in time and I think we're all in
agreement we have a housing crisis so
could we
add at the end of that paragraph
and tackle the current housing crisis
then all of a sudden this
document looks as though we understand
the problems we've got that there is a
housing crisis it doesn't specifically
point out one solution but it does
highlight that we are aware there's a
housing crisis and I also think that
would help counselors at the next stage
when we look at operational approaches
be able to say don't forget social
because we need it because we're all in
agreement that we've got a crisis if we
haven't got that crisis status which is
the now then perhaps that weakens the
hands of the ones who want to see a bit
more radical change and I think that
would also influence the local plan
considerably on the planning side which
I agree is the biggest tool we we've got
it's something we can do something
about I'd second
that um yes the the initial resp is say
the council will tackle the housing
crisis the council won't tackle housing
crisis on its own we're never going to
be able to deliver and sort out the
entire housing crisis on our own it's
crisis across the country it's not a
single um point of failure there's
multiple things that are impacted so um
I think if you put a comment in it say
we will tackle it and solve it you set
yourself up to
fail I can I just come back on that um
we we have actually already said that we
are going to meet the housing needs of
the district which I also would say we
won't um I don't think we will ever meet
every housing need um but I do take your
point Steve and you know so contribute
towards tackling the housing crisis
perhaps would be a more measured
wording I believe counc C hunin put her
hand up and then councel
craigy and then counc benan in that
order after that that St line it was
just say instead of and Tackle you could
just say to help to tackle the housing
crisis and then it's still in there it
makes it clear like you said we're in a
housing crisis and I second that that
should be added to the Strategic plan I
don't understand why there should be a
problem
that yeah I was just going to request a
recorded vote on the
Amendments just going to say chair that
our problem has been that housing has
been an economic driver not meeting a
social need and until we go back and
think of things from a social point of
view rather than an economic point of
view we ain't going to go anywhere with
this housing crisis because we have to
make a profit I was in Lam the other day
and I was talking to one of our new
residents and they sold a property for
1.1 million and bought a 500,000 pound
property and got 600,000 pound taxfree
to put in their pension pot now we can't
get our locals to compete with that and
the issues we need to think about is
something from central government um
that that sets some rules that does
protect part of the community if we not
going down the council housing line and
I see with sadness there's a house in in
Lum on the market at the present moment
that was a council house in the 1940s
now just gone on the market a lovely
beautiful house and then it was right to
buy I don't blame people wanting to
Aspire to the right to buy but we also
need to create and I would remind you
also that when appal ship Builders came
to talk to external
ons um they talked about now trying to
get the work first up to 300 people on a
wage of about 303,000 a year and that
wasn't enough for those workers to buy a
house within the area and there is the
endemic problem that we are in because
even good wages within the area are not
now buying the houses and and there's no
nothing left to rent because it's been
Airbnb and we do need to think outside
the box and I think it's also lobbying
central government because the issues of
a low wage economy and a high house
price and still we beat that block we
ain't going to go anywhere and I'd like
to see some aspiration to challenge more
central government thank you
chair across St uh we've got uh a set up
holos transort which is is a combination
of all district councils U including J
County
Council I think still in that that
meeting um and that that's with a view
of lobbying government for different
changes different quality changes uh
because we recognize as I said earlier
it's not one point of failure there a be
the private rent sector R local closing
allowance they're all separate factors
that are contributing to a much greater
problem so that the role of that task
force and the Housing Commission has
been set up and coun James the leaders
on the task force is to look at all
those points look at all the CA and
effects and uh with the intention of
getting policy changes uh making
government see the problems that bring
some for to the posing system so that is
already in place and be affected with
through that mechanism
[Music]
thans of
ideas the issue is this is a draft plan
Tack and we need a strategy on the local
plan and us in trouble on Friday a
little bit for pushing it um we do need
and it will be a Hos lead section within
that um working um gr going to be
looking at there so we know you know
spend 20 years during affordable housing
in the holworthy area on Friday the
government annc no sorry the thir
November the government announced some
money that we can use to start working
with um
uh facilitators
or enablers to actually start looking at
we provide areas for our young people so
make sure they stay if you look at the
Govern
home L some of you will remember and
Rose isn't here tonight but Rose will
remember that to actually fought against
that to start with because there's no
priority for local youngsters on that
list so we man to get to be prioritized
for locals on that but if you're a young
couple looking for a host they wasting
your time putting your name on at the
knee at the moment because you won't get
any corers my perspective is we need a
strategy that's tying all this together
and move it forward I'm quite happy to
see I think we're all happy and want to
see more social housing that is not the
issue the issue is how we use the
Strategic plan to drive the housing of
to forward
and some of these vits will come into
that and we will do with it but we don't
want to end up with a plan a a strategic
plan and we're spending time working on
one specific P that will come within the
affordable housing working group we've
also got to think it's fine to say we
want more social housing how are we
going to do it we haven't got offices
we've lost half some years ago we be
funding question of they have changed
the rules a bit in so much as we can now
go up to
199 um before we have to become a
registered RP and that is not easy we've
looked at it in holsworthy it's just an
awful lot of work becoming an RP and to
um the people I talk to to do with
housing there's an issue coming now that
the government through homes England are
not releasing the amount of money they
were releasing so all of this will have
to be investigate it yes we can
prioritize it within the work we're
doing but specifically to prioritize it
we will not end up with a strategy to
deal with everything and I'd just like
to make that point that we need to deal
with posing and we need to get on with
it state has been quite successful in
dealing with Tas we've still got some
you know we are you know we're ahead in
so much as the pods that all can start
being used now
we've got others we're looking at so
we're dealing with as much as we can and
there will be a demand for soal POS
there was strong as years ago um youd
have to go back to how
timeing Villages um so I spoke to Sean
about the government money to look at
Ena us to try and build up a picture and
all of this will give us some evidence
that go forward to the government we go
forward saying we want money uh to do
help your hosting they're going to say
what's your
plan if we haven't got one we are not
going to get any money so we let get a
plan we can we can look at it we going
social
housing be doing it you know this idea
that for some reason we're it simply not
true but we do need to be build a case
to Pro provide all the evidence you
won't get any money unless you can back
it up and do it so please let's just get
on with the plan and yes we within it we
can make sure we deal with social
housing but at the moment to deal
with said about what we doing now we're
working the rest with hes to see what
they can
do now by time we set up um the
structure we need to deliver you're
going to be several years down the road
so good we need to do it now and the
quickest way is to support um a
registered provider that's doing it not
get W down by trying to do it ourselves
up nothing so yes I'm happy that we are
trying to do more with social noing but
in the short term our best bet is either
doing with t or working with a housing
group actually deliver them much quicker
than we can
thank
you before we get on to the
uh
on we've got two you've got two
amendments so the first amendment was
councelor and CRA seed by councelor
Brenton which was Toc the construction
of social houses social homes that's the
first one the second one is from Piper
seconded by councelor H um hin exing for
me to say which is to contribute towards
tackling the current housing crisis um
or councelor James has propos that we
adopt as is so do you
want councelor
James's so C grees first is that the
first
one to facilitate the constru conu of
social H all in favor all in favor
[Music]
please didn't get get agreement for the
recorded
V sorry ask for a
second break
second five members to agree record vote
another there
you
all
righty coun
Andrews yeah sorry um
yeah thank you coun back
abstain councelor Annie Brenton PA
councelor David Brenton for councelor
Chris brigh against councelor Lauren
brigh against councel bushby
against councel cot huny against because
i' did councelor
tiers counc
craigy councelor
Dart
again councel Elliot
against councelor Gibson
against councelor G
abstain councelor hackit
against councelor haes for
councel Harding against councel Hawkins
for councel Hudson
against councelor inch against councelor
James against councelor Johns
against councelor Le against councelor L
for councelor Newton against councelor
Pennington
for councelor Piper
against councelor Shephard for councelor
Smith against councelor weatley
against councelor Whitaker against thank
you yeah that's nine for 19 against and
two
extensions
second yeah so this is to contribute
toward tackling the current housing
crisis
coun
coun recorded
was so all in favor then in support of
that
motion
yeah
I any any
against
extensions
okay moving on to the actual dra
strategic being prop
James who seconded that has second for
the chair all in favor please
show
and
against
exensions 264 for abstentions
J some's out up
[Music]
yeah to item 15 leveling up partnership
ages 110
119 quite long as well got a bit to run
through um so when the the agenda was
said we purposely put this on a
strategic plan because it do nicely uh F
on from that um so perhaps before I go
start going through the report some of
the details it's probably worth
reflective I'm sure there's some
confusion certainly some confusion with
us what a level in that partnership
actually is and what it entails and what
we need to do um as an
authority um so ultimately the report
provides our current position statement
and match the the progress we've made to
date so firstly I think as we're
pointing out it's it's a government
policy uh which is led by the
Departments of Le po communities um and
it's a partnership is led by GAC and we
torage didn't decide to form this
partnership we were selected uh to form
the
partnership um secondly it's worth I
playing a few of the the key phrases
that g Department uh gave set out around
what a leveling up partnership
is so it's the area is identified in the
spring budget to be invited to form a
partnership with
d and in terms a partnership is about
bringing together all leevers of
government and it's a bespoke place
based approach to
policymaking and recognizing the unique
challenges and opportunities and area
faces in the short to medium turn and
seeks to divide a PO program that
supports that to improve that area
there's a couple of key points in there
um that reflects it it's the area and a
place based
partnership and also reflecting that the
wide range and challenges that the area
faces and that kind of points Us in the
direction that it's about a much wider
partnership not just about the district
council but about torage as a place and
that's entally why we'll be talking
about a place space a place board which
I'll come back to a little bit
later I guess then we're
thinking what's what's pge's role in
this if it's a a partnership with the
area rather than partnership directly
with torage
counseling um so as a council uh we the
lead's convener AL plac for our role is
bringing together all the relevant
Partners all the
organizations across the district
bringing those to the table ultimately
the
board we aren't experts in everything
that happens across the area um we talk
about housing we talked about social
housing and those partners that deliver
that and there's the health sector
education sector well we know a lot
about our area we're not experts in all
of those and many other fields it's
about facilitating discussions and
Communications between the government
Department their policy team um
discussions with political discussions
with the ministers the MP which the
believe and I have been engaged with and
all of the partners across the district
and of the board and with yourselves of
forage come for us there's wiser
stakeholders to engage with parish and
town councils our residents and our
communities and businesses they will
form part of the colage the
areum ultimately though charage um
should there be any fund being allocated
to a partnership will be the accountable
body to will be responsible for any
funding that might come our way
especially if it's delivering any large
Capital related
projects we'll be responsible for the
delivery of those projects and a work
program again especially if the captive
projects and accept the risks and
ultimately youo Council would needs to
approve anything uh that the any
particular projects the the partnership
is take forward Al this resour
implications from us Etc
and we've been managing the flow of data
ideas and things between the board
between government and between our
communities so I I I kind of indicated
we like a conductor we like pulling
together the orchestra around the place
making sure things are going in in the
right direction set set a Tempo and O
overall own in the
agenda that's just kind of a little bit
of background and to what the
partnership might look
like as has been pointed out counc
Brenton mentioned about
P we talked about skills we talked about
aspirations our our younger population
being able to buide properties so the
partnership the reason po has being
selected um is because of our low levels
of eny2 level three progression because
of our grow weekly pay being low because
of our uh output levels being low and
because we don't have healthly long life
expectancy for our residents so they the
metrics the government have used to
identify identify the torage
area um we talked a couple of times
surround the time frames it have been a
little bit confusing what they might be
um but following a meeting uh councelor
James
uh s Jeffrey Cox and I had with the the
minister but that meeting was delayed
somewhat because it was a a change of
ministry responsibilities but we had
that meeting it's being confirmed uh
that we are working to a March 24 uh
launch uh so during
March before that formal launch we'll
have an introductory meeting with the
minister
and um the leveling up policy team for
civil servants will also meet with us in
advance of that formal start what's
called a deep dive process I'll come
back to that not my
terminology um and that process will run
between April and June of next year and
we understand from our discussions with
with the team that will be quite an
intensive exercise and involve
uh a lot of key stakeholders and
partners as well as the
council so one of the the things we have
to do in preparation for that process
and some of the things we've been
working on um is first firstly defining
the
geography um up until now and in other
areas uh the government policy has been
centered around um urban areas this the
first partnership
uh that started in a in a rural
District so ordinarily that uh
partnership has been center around an
urban city area um and there's the
policy defines that you should be
working around that area um now quite
clearly um in torage District that would
be pip so anything would ordinarily be
centered around B good but quite clearly
we reflect that there something be R for
the entire District not just one part of
the district I'm sure you all support
that um needing to consider how a
leveling a partnership might align uh to
other work we're doing now clearly we're
doing work in app through the the
leveling up fund and some of that work
uh we aim to bring to the tables through
the the partnership because that's about
upskilling um bringing a higher higher
paid Employments here
establishing a gathering strong evidence
base U it's all built around data uh
data modeling data evidence data
Gathering is what will drive uh this
forward and drive the government's
decisions on whether to invest money in
the
area um pulling together our list of
external stakeholders that the
partnership teeme will engage with so
private public third sector
and any other stakeholders who were able
to build up that picture of the place as
wide as possible and that's kind of
where we were directed towards the
development of the place board that's
what's being used in other areas and
what's Works in other areas particularly
around to Deals and such um so looking
at the the priorities for Tage for the
partnership obviously the Strategic plan
as you just approved is part of that Pro
part of that Gathering um and
identifying the challenges and
opportunities OB are plan you identify
some of those uh priorities
already uh one of the key things is
considering resourcing and capacity
obviously if there are projects to be
delivered by the council we need to
consider how we resource them on top of
the projects we already doing
and we've we play that message back to
to the
minister what have we' been doing uh
some of the work that we have already
done um as I said we have to prepare for
that March
start um so we had a number of detents
with the Department with the officer
team from daac and
B as the the guidance has been um I'd
say somewhat limited and touching on
what we said a little bit vague so we'
be working with the teams and try and
understand how this emerging quity uh
fits with us uh we've been assigned a
regional
lead next part October we got a couple
of visits from the team and we've given
them a tour of the district showing um
areas from bord
ton so given them a general tour of the
the district
uh we've got a further meeting scheduled
with the the actual National policy team
so the official de in January in advance
City official start to make sure we're
on TR to delivering what they need in
terms of data Gathering and evidence U
before that March
starts um we've been working with
colleagues at The Count Council obiously
not all the data and evidence we hold
ourselves so we in collaborative with
we U we're in the process of
commissioning some work on developing uh
what we turn as the place story uh and
the picture of T So building all of that
data together all things about wages
jobs
skills are some kind of evidence story
um that tells the government what is
like what are concern what are and what
the opportunities are for the
partnership um you'll see from the the
reports OB we've been developing a draft
Place board uh and that's on your agenda
for tonight for consideration and
hopefully approval U that's
representative um across sectors but
also picks up places across District or
else we recognize a number of SE needs
to be covered it's hopefully useful to
have some of those Bas around District
as
well um what the place board isn't isn't
it's not a Council Place board and so
it's not shared by the council by the
the leader or any other elected member
it acts independently of the council um
it's as I said it's established through
um those professional experts in
different fields uh to facilitate the
discussions between between the council
between the the government department
and help guide that agenda U so it'll be
the leveling up pocy team that will be
developing a report to present with
recommendations to the minister for what
that team uh thinks um will work in
terms of interventions for area so
Independence of the council and the
council won't be bound by any decisions
of our it's not intended that they would
be making decisions as they an advisory
representative
body um so the other pieces of work uh
which feed in quite critically um which
being worked on is the the norende
economic strategy uh that's currently
almost in
a verion and again that's built on
evidence we've got the the northern
northern Poes strategy uh which feeds to
Northern Devon pies and again looks at
The Wider Northern Devon area because
quite clearly things that we do in our
district uh have an impact and effect in
our neighboring districts as well and
and vice for obiously just approved the
stre Strategic plan and recently
approved that we'll move forward with a
new joint
local so we've also been working
collaboratively with is at North Deon um
Devon County and the local Enterprise
partnership that currently exists around
some of those wider Ambitions
opportunities Around clean Maritime
prodction and green energy generation
and it clearly linked to what's
happening the work at Bor and some of
the emerging bloating opore winds
opportunities uh that may present
themselves to this area and there clear
links to some of the other energy pieces
that going on um as I mentioned earlier
capacity and resources clearly a concern
um but um as are things like housing
needs because if going to regenerate and
rebuilds the economy of the area then
that would need to come with housing and
other Resorts infrastructure resor
this um so that's a kind of snapshot of
where we are um the the cord is I said
set out in the report I want to go
through that in detail I answer any
questions and I believe that the leader
to stay
a sorry
Chief a um just say to the chief except
that really is good description of what
we're doing we have struggle it un
struggled in it exactly how it's all
going to work I'll P Ste on that that
really is exactly how it is um and I
think what you can see on page 14 is all
the stuff we're involved in on your iPad
oh sorry 114
114 how much we're involved in and what
we should be saying to ourselves this is
exciting this is a chance to do what we
keep wanting to do which is the area um
I know there's some doubs as often there
is um but the opportunities are there
and what we've got to do and it's all
there we've got the strategy we can use
that to base on where we're going um
we've got the stuff on Apple door that
flow that I just think it's exciting
times but we need to deliver and the the
beauty of it of what we've decided
recently if we take a local plan you
going start it in the Autumn we've only
got 13 hopefully the new local plan
hopefully we get agreement we've only
got 30 months to deliver it this one
we've got to start the end of March and
you never know a cou mons the sooner we
get on with it and get Stu done the more
likely we are to deliver it so I just
feel that this is really good our
officers have got a good handle on it
we've had very POS good response when we
did meet the ler and the civil servants
um let's just get over with there you
know really I'm not
discussion I just want to get over give
me a Shel I'll give you a ho you want
a so let's get on with it so thank
you thank you um just a question um how
much money are we actually getting for a
leveling up partnership we know it's a
share of 400 million but when will we
find out how much we're actually
getting um there there's no alloc
specific
allocation um as I said earlier the
leveling up policy team will make
recommendations to the minister uh so
when they consider uh what interventions
there are for the area that will
determine whether or not there any
condition we was there 400 million en
local Authority areas it's not a
straight split so I know there's been
talk with 20 million because that's the
obvious split um and the minister
mentioned that figure to us but
obviously it's driven by what the
interventions may
be you
just I would apologize I should have
move the recommendations that on page
one one set
I'll counc ha you've got your yeah I've
got three questions first of all what's
the counselor input involvement of all
this it all seems to be driven by
officers and external forces so what say
are we going to continue to have the
second thing is a note on the forage
place for biosphere chief executive is
responsible for that why Earth isn't it
Andy Bell with the biosphere
um the other Fact one I'm wearing is um
one of the remits is a healthy life um
well as far as I concerned that involves
climate change um brouts pollution
flooding that all has an effect on
health so why is there not L on the
board to do with the environment climate
change possibly Don Sibly our joint
climate officer would fulfill that role
so those my three questions my my answer
to you checking question I think Andy
Bell is the CH exective of that board
he's going to be he is or thank
youed putting individual names on there
because OB we didn't want to start
discuss discussing people but obviously
by association when you know the
organization in position that that can
quite easily be worked
out sorry to if I'm come back on the
environment then may I propose that we
include a person on the board to deal
with environments and possibly done
a need a second I'll
second I'm sorry we've got a set of
criteria where we need to address those
things and as you said we've got the mil
on there and no doubt it will come up in
other sections but we can't put people
on that board just to deal with one
particular
thing whole area
we're deal with people that specialize
in stuff yes there will be people
specializ in that environment and
whatever you but that's not that's been
this is why we're going wrong as it
sometimes we just keep on almost dealing
with our own personal
wish of his healthy
life so I just wanted adding to the list
there's no mention of art culture her
sorry Arts culture and
Heritage the strateg sorry that's
covered by the Strategic plan which
we've already about the board theist of
people on the board again put people on
the board for specific areas they have
to be specialists in their area um and
so you know the board will go on and on
we could have a board of 36 or 40 and
and still be discussing this in 10 years
time what we've got is a board that
we've been given a guidance to if the
types of areas we need to look at and
that's what we've
done you've got the biosphere which
relates to healthy wildlife and relates
to a healthy life as for in the criteria
which being presented because um we
couldn't exist properly without a
healthy biosphere we couldn't exist
properly without healthy environment SOS
we have um we include a representative
for the environment on the
board
surely Andy Bell who as we all know is
you know probably the lead lead
individual on the BIOS own on the board
as givea surely that would surp not the
impacts of climate change
na he has a specific role please St
chair you you've also got myself Sean
the leader of the council um on that
board who will reflect everything the
council wants to achieve through our
strategic plan and through our other
plans and strategies and that's the the
purpose of having Bo as well so we
counil Representatives Bri I'm just
thinking that I've understood it say the
the police board structure this is what
it says in the report on page 115 is
based on examples of other is operating
elsewhere which we've been directed
towards so just because this table is
what's comeing to us on this report I I
agree with councelor haes if we wanted
to make a change to it this hasn't been
given to us laid down to us by anyone
this is something that the council is
putting forward and agreeing to tonight
and so if we want to make a change to it
I don't think that that's been Deni that
that option's being denied To Us by
anybody if that's what we want to do
vote to do it as a council why can't we
do
it nobody said you can't do iten see on
to
it VI opinions have been reflected
through those members on the board from
the council so the
leader
communities
reference
the say can't be change
I
don't
get specific
to the needs of
our got a second to
chair
presum Steve this if you were to put
environment
on I mean the the
responsibilities actually mask the name
of an individual that you've got on here
and you you've selected or gone for
individuals who are regionally leaders
of their of their area are subject
matter experts right that you we've
masked it at the moment because You'
just put the era that they but in fact
what you've really got underlying there
is a list of names I the
fa if there is somebody of that level
who can
actually
contribute alongside everybody else in
that category then why not but rather
than just putting the the function there
it needs a name first of somebody who's
who's going to really bring value to
that
board say to that is we're trying to
deal with areas that we're doing if we
start picking individuals then I'm sure
in this room we probably come up with a
whole load of individuals and I think
again we becoming parure we're not
looking at the bigger picture of the
people you know we've got North D
Hospital You could argue it's not in Tor
but it has a major effect on this area
and there's probably two or three people
in that group that would do it you know
you want the board we're actually up to
the number that when we other areas that
that sort of number and it's the same
all the way you know we can put names to
it and then we end up person what we're
looking at is the bigger picture what we
need to to get it all together we dve It
Forward we're going to do short time um
and yeah I I don't see the benefit of
put because if you put a name there You'
then got to justify why that person's
there and we end up did somebody justify
the other
way I wasn't suggesting you put names in
there now I just saying that the the the
method behind is is that you're actually
heading for key people who are major
drivers in these various
areas that's what they're trying to do
find the key people in those
areas functional areas sorry functional
areas functional areas you can't rack
environment together like that no yeah
we've got um we're looking at for people
within education within Health um the
different businesses we've also because
it's college wide when we've looked at
the business is we've looked at the
areas so that we've sort of tried to do
the two things together is to pick areas
and also come up as Specialists within
that area obviously if you look after
you think about St around Marine Center
and stuff like
that to got actually a really good
skills man from ton who actually has the
skills board you
know that's the sort of thing you need
to do you've got to look at the bigger
picture time is against us with this
anyway we got to get it in place I'm
sorry right first then's go thank you CH
uh Le you say that we can't pick into
idual but this this is actually a list
of individuals that already been picked
I'm so struggling to square that round I
mean I don't see why we can't suggest an
area to find an expert and then say well
we put that expert in you know is that
really going to be that difficult for us
to do we say we're not we're not
stopping people from doing it but you're
making it very
difficult okay the other thing I
me I mentioned earlier when I was doing
the presentation is the team will want
to engage Eng with other stakeholders uh
so if the team the policy team identify
that they need some specialist input or
reference uh to people with climate
responsibility or different
environmental credentials credentials
they will ask and we will direct them
towards that um so it's not a a finite
list of everybody they will speak to
um seems to be logical way well we've
agreed the strategy we've agreed that
we're going to put business um
programs therefore you're going to end
up with an input from torage based on
our strategy and the business plans that
we do so on environment you have an
input that goes into that strategy from
the environment and
also
so to put that on the let's say you want
someone from the environment you can
find who you want but we want to put it
as an option
there
just
ask do we want M or
AAL government want us to look at now we
either want it you've already answered
some of our questions or some of the
questions from the floor when you say
you're going to engaged as you go
on in a wider spectrum of people I
actually think that b to result at least
for this evening I want to see this
money coming here I mean God know we
waited long enough to get any these
amount of money haven't we into this
District so let's not Cloud the issue
now here please let's just crack on with
it i' just like to um ask about haer's
feeds under uh HW the
agricultural agriculture is going
through Chang at the moment the
presentent payment schemes are changing
to the environmental Land Management
schemes in the next um five or six years
there's a huge going on about the use of
land anybody attended plants committee
last Thursday saw I think our planning
committee have a huge battle about what
use of land will be for the future and
who should be actually striving forward
for the future and I would like to see
somebody from the primary industry in
agriculture representing the rural areas
because this reads to me as
Ben aquador Northern and torington but
there's a hell of a lot more than there
is just in that situation and I'm a
little bit concerned that we're not
asking the primary industry who used
most of the land across page at the
present moment I think it's over 82% if
I remember rightly from the B to put
their input because they are vitally
important to be heard because they
provide a lot of the the the wages and
the leveling up we need that base and
not just a supply uh chain remember
there
come we put thatt there but we know the
individual the already done all this
work for formal on in Ro Enterprises and
stuff like that so whil this is where we
fall into not naming people when we know
that we've got somebody who expert in
working in not just with the feed
although the feed will come a little bit
from what we're doing in appledore there
is link and what we have to do is to
show the links but the individual has
got has worked on Agro business and AGR
Tech the coral he's done Project work
he's also done a lot of work with um the
where we're going with the SFI and stuff
like that so in my opinion and I put his
name forward that he he delivers a
package that will deal with the whole of
the royal area rather than somebody who
stealing an Pacific area
AG not forget James is on the board and
he is a former as
well so well
sorry you wanted to come back on I just
want to make one more Point yeah just on
the apple one I mean it does bother me a
bit hor wolf because uh if hor wolf got
to make a choice between a leveling up
thing for Belfast or aquador I mean it's
like having um somebody from outside the
area um on the board and I'm just a
little bit concerned that I would sooner
choose an an indigenous industry rather
than things an industry that has just
come in in the last I think five years
um hor been an appledor and they may
come and go again we've seen appledor
come and go but you we need somebody
with a fe for that and it's just a
comment about the app situation there
that I'm
making well all I say to that is the
people that we've got in mind people
that are recognized nationally and that
will give us allos as we go forward with
the board um you know there are lots of
successful businesses around many of
them selfmade businesses we can't
include all of them and what we're
looking at this because they're there
partly for the the the place part of the
story and that's what I did say we're
looking at who we pick from the bord
Northern Area door area who we looking
from toron and who we looking from to
try and get
some the whole area some
representation these people are experts
in their and the government's going to
listen to
them another can we please make that the
last a long to do on the
agenda last well I'm I'm on board with C
on this there's up to 20 million pounds
available up to 20 million you heard
earlier on it was mentioned that
normally this leveling up Ling goes to
the urban area is the larger towns we
fitting we are a rural area that's had
the chance now to get up to 20 million
pound so don't quar the pitch just
accept this as it says on do of page 115
TDC will not be bound by decisions of
the Facebook we won't be bound by lots
of outside agencies and bodies will
contribute will give evidence and we'll
contribute we just
second second what my proposal which was
about 15 minutes
ago I didn't see a
second so that was to
include a person on the board to deal
with
environment so we'll take that one first
because that's so you don't agree with
that Amendment we'll go back to the
report okay all this all support of C
H's motion
faal again
sorry oh exensions yes
sorry that's 12 for 15 against and three
extensions
by all in favor
please anyone against
it
against and
abstentions
right good again all in favor please
show motion
clear CH
be and against and
extensions 26 for and four
exensions
I know it's
but anyone
else
still got quite a lot to get through on
the agenda and it's just com 9:00 so
item 16 on your agenda is Con allowances
page 20 to 22
gladly over to members for their
consideration um so um I guess the the
pay award for all officers has been
agreed uh
recently um fortunately unfortunately it
was paid at a l some value this time as
it was last year so there's a different
decision for you as coun to consider how
to apply any if if we should to apply an
increase to counselor
allowances U soat plat weight Award of
1925 for the majority of Staff um
allowances were increased by
3.88% the the pay Award of 19 1925 by
equates to around
6.72% that's an increase and the uh pay
awards for the chief officers and myself
agreed at
3.5% um the sub information contained in
the report around inflation rates and
how other benefits and pensions are
being
increased um on the second page of the
report page 121 sets out your current
scheme of
allowances I should point out that you
can't approve any changes to that
particular scheme other than increases
to the individual allowances you can't
introduce new member allowances for any
other responsibilities unless a
recommendation is made to take back to
an independent remuneration fund
regulations require you to consider um
the views of independent ration panel
should you wish to change that scheme uh
so chair um I guess it's all members to
consider their recommendations and what
if any increase you wish to to make
I
sorry youve
done well obviously as they I need to
make
my recommendation is for
youself I spent the whole weekend trying
to work out fig and fig and we've come
up today with this that we can't change
sorry we can't change the um the
different payments that's we do an
independent review um and that's not on
the C at the moment but it could beers
want to do it and that means that
whether you change um the amount that
goes to
um need mbers or to whether you look at
F CHS again if you go back to the last
independent review which was
2019 the independent board recommended
we did pay um lead members and we didn't
pay most chairs because almost everybody
would be getting an additional payment
because if take everybody into a c so
we're left really is do we increase it
at all or do we not increase it
when you look at it we are as a council
behind most of the other District
councils what's been recommended in
North de where they move towards a
higher figure they can do that over a
couple of years because they've done it
part of their paral review so we can't
do that so in very simple terms it's do
we go with the 3.88 which is the using
which is what we've been recommended to
do is to follow
the allowances that go in the special
allowances that go to
um no not special the actual allowance
that members are entitled to um
for you you mean the St yeah theor the
St allowances for things other than
their wages and traveling obious
trly differently on basis so in my view
and you can you know we struggle to get
consensus tonight but in my view that
because there is some concern about lead
members and there can be a lot of work
if you look at what's going on we're
going to be here discussing stuff every
meeting about where we're going the
different things and I would just
suggest that we go for the 3.8 and next
year we go for the um the uh the
allowance that those two um stuff that
is their basic alowance so that we
possibly add that tonight so that we
don't have this again next year if we
decide that's what we're going to do
that will come in
automatically and
then way doing
it
through it all um but there was an awful
lot of work that needs to be done and I
think as a council um we should
recognize that and also if we do do an
independent review in the future if
we're not tackling the issues as we go
we will end up with a massive that we
have to come in with to balance up um so
we could then be saying you know stand
here saying we need a lot of money
actually get us to the stand other
counil on so most of them are adopting
the the increase of the basic low of
this far just to try and keeping the L
going and that's what I think we should
be doing I'm really um I've looked at it
I worked on it in the night other night
and quite honestly my easi would be just
come here and say what you want to do
if you ask me out because we feel some
people are being a little underu we
can't nothing we go to the EXP
206 a year and we move on you
know need to get on with the council
everything
tonight with
it I'm not going to be
any than you br thank you chair I move
the
recommendation three namely no increase
you've seen all the statistics tonight
about the area that we live in how depri
deprived it is and economically poor it
sends us wrong message that elected
members should be voting any sort of
increase at all it's just not right and
I think it uh you know you don't have to
do everything for money for some of us
for years have been on as you know chair
governing bodies not doing putting in
time
voluntarily Town council's never used to
have allowances either you know if you
can't as a as a citizen put some time
into your community without getting a
big reward for it then you you shouldn't
be doing it so um as I say I recommend
the
three second
[Music]
that yeah well I'm going to disagree
with Council Bron I think we should P
the
3.88% we've not had a rise in the
allowance for four years now 2019 was
the
lap and to attract new members
especially people who work I think it's
it's fair enough that you get a
reasonable allowance for the work you do
now some councils do far more than
others but what I would say is when when
we look into the future we really have
to address the issue of lead members
because lead members and I think
increasingly so do a lot of work in this
Council over the next four years but
there's a b basic allowance I worked it
out it's
about7 24 a month addition before tax
that's all it is it's not that big a
deal but I I think on the overall budget
puts about 8,000 9,000 on
the
but
you 3.8 number one and and all this
about lots of us do work voluntarily in
lots of different ways but this is a
different thing all together and we want
to attract I'd like to attract younger
people to join the council who maybe
work and I remember years back when I
was working I used to take time off from
work and I was glad had got an allowance
which kind of compensated a bit for
coming on to the council doing but you
know we all do work in I think probably
most of is involved in things outside
the country but this is aair it still
leaves us behind some of the district
council you seconded James's
propos I just check and that that that
allowance be app
for consecutive years
automatically link to
that order at the outset of this debate
councelor James said that he was going
to leave it to us to make a decision and
then he come forward with the
recommendation he was he said he wasn't
you know going to leave it to us and
then that's why I po up with my hand up
well long didn't I you w know that came
up with a recommendation three so
actually he did have a a proposal to put
forward didn't but he didn't propose at
the time at the outset you did not
propose that I withraw
my right okay but let's address the
business of council Lea about lead
members Etc I agree we should have a
review of the special responsibilities
they do need revie they're not right
there's no two questions about it but we
need a group leaders meeting tonight I
know you're very happy about them but we
do need a group leaders meeting about
that so we can sort out how that should
be done fairly and get agreement before
it ever comes to council okay we should
not be having those sort of debates in
the public domain it doesn't look good
not right counc thank you chair um what
a horrible
subject um I don't think any of us
comfortable in talking about it but it's
reality and I completely agree with
councelor Le um I wouldn't like to see a
situation where good local people who
are embedded in their
communities
can't become a counselor and that would
absolutely be the reality if we all said
we've got to give up significant
time I know we all we a lot of people on
this counil give up significant time I
appreciate the fact that we have an
allowance I have a mortgage I have two
young children I have a wife who
BDI looks at me a lot of the time when I
spend a lot of time in my work time
because to be be a good councelor I've
realized you've got to separate put
aside good quality time in the daytime
and that means your work takes backseat
and that and at this time um you know it
amazes me how people are making ends
meet and I think if we freeze as per
councelor Brenton's um recommendation
that is a significant cut it is not
keeping things as it is it is a
significant cut I think 3.88 is um
respectful to other people staff Chief
Executives people that have got similar
um raises and it keeps things moving
forward with momentum so I I completely
agree with Council
leather coun
Le yeah I'll make it the proposal then
in the councilor with the proposal I'll
make the
proposal the
allowances
second very good points move raised here
I think um all because we haven't had an
increase doesn't mean we have to have an
increase um as a younger person who
works I work for my money I think being
a counselor is a is a privilege and um I
I feel it's not the money side that
makes me want to become a
counselor um also to have money as an
incentive to entice younger people
shouldn't be the way we want to bring
people in we just want to bring people
in who want to do the job and that's it
respect I don't think the money
that collect each year is going is an
incentive for anyone to
be so we need to take the
[Music]
amendment yes I think we're looking at
this the I said we're looking up the
wrong end of the municipal drain pipe
and I cannot
believe that two labor members are
leveling down our
allowances because let's look at
it nationally I believe the true figures
are around £6,000 a year why should it
be less in
torage I'm going to make this argument
we have a demographic age deficit on
this Council especially at members
workshops when we get members who can't
attend because they're working we need
to make sure that they are correctly
remunerated with their allowances to
allow them to take the time off you know
if I look around this room we've got 36
sh of grade okay I'm going to get picked
from very close order but we need that
young element we're not talking about
the people here today we're looking for
the Next
Generation I went up to Parliament a few
years ago and I met the member for Le a
labor member who said that local
councils are the Cradle of
democracy it's not something to bolster
up our pensions when we're older we need
that younger element in we need to
encourage them and we might just have a
homegrown MP that goes on in the future
to represent us from our
community let's look at it from the long
term not the short term for what we need
you know a lot of
us we've had our time we've got to get
the younger people involved and we'll
only do that if we give them the correct
allowances so I'm strongly on board the
3.88 thank you okay well coun Brenton's
motion was seconded by councelor shepher
so take that first of all all the
support of that motion that we don't
have any in at
show against
and
abstentions okay come on to C
others
sorry yeah yeah six for 18 against and
three
chair councel haes wasn't in the room
and two left at the
break okay counc other is proposing that
we move the allowance to
3.88% seconded by I
believe C Harding all in favor please
show
okay and
against
exensions 23 for five against and one
abstention item
17 under proced
Ru first one we got three questions that
have been received and first one was
from P Brenton te
[Music]
the don't makeing
remark right counselors well this
answer doesn't answer my question at all
my question wasn't disputing the fact
that we got iPad saw the history of them
and then they were introduced and the
digital by
strategy and the continued reduction in
music associated with services like
postage it was about our actual use of
them and how user friendly they are to
counselors because we have a bit of a
different circumstance from the staff
using the system um with these
iPads and you know call me somebody who
isn't very tech savvy but you know I
found it very difficult
to overcome some of the problems I've
encountered on there I mean I'm bed up
with something saying to me S Safari
can't open this page fed up with it um
John knows that I've had lots of
problems um with some of the emails um
the request for commitments years ahead
I understand why people are making those
requests but in fact it clogs up the
system incred L um it confuses you and
it confuses me anyway and 39 emails
rearrangements and subse subsequent
changes to committee dates doesn't help
you to sort through to find out the
things that really are your
priorities um also loads of counselors
telling me that they are or are not
going to give a contribution to St
Margaret's girls Christmas lunch you
know I don't really need to know that in
fact you know it's you can't see the
woods for the trees because of these Sy
there's an overload of non-specific data
on our emails but it's not just that
trying to keep hold of the agenda on
here is incredibly difficult I don't
know if there is something about time
delay and all that and when it kind
turns off but I do think there should be
special arrangements for the um agenda
on both Council because we've had long
meetings and it just mine keeps
switching off and then it whizzes back
to the beginning and you know it takes a
bit of a while to get back on track
again so my point was that there's an
erratic presentation Council agenda
reports and contents and that there
there's no archive on here if I wanted
to look at council meeting in 2021 or 22
which I might want to do for some reason
research or whatever where is it I don't
know where there's an archive on here it
isn't on not mod gar as well as I can
see so my question was about why when
when is it reviewed in terms of
counselor input it was about asking for
what somebody else has already talked
about tonight about counselor input into
how the system works whoever that would
be there may be there's obviously much
more competent people on or in this room
than me who could do something about
that and help but I do feel that as
there's 36 people here who use this
system that we should have some input in
the grounds of on the grounds of
equality about the way it's implemented
the way they're using it it could be
once every four years or whatever I
don't know I'm not being specific about
that but I do feel and I know I'm not
the only one who's encountered
difficulties that you know the system
could be I'm sure improved by a bit of
the counselors the laid members the lay
elected members into the system to just
make it more user friendly to counselors
that's what my question was about it
wasn't criticizing the fact that we got
them or when they went into Bas or
whatever they might you know the answer
to my question it completely
misrepresents what I was asking and or
don't understand it that might be my
fault probably is but that's what I was
asking I was asking if we can have some
kind of input as counselors into the way
things are produced and going and I
don't see why we couldn't have a small
group hopefully those who are most
confus to Savvy as I'd say to help the
staff or whoever does this to make it a
better service for everybody involved
and I think that's a win-win situation
really and I don't see why it should be
conted thank
you next question is
from discuss oh it was just some thanks
actually because it's related to the
iPads and I won't name who it was but a
member of my group was really struggling
with using the iPads but the beginning
found it quite daunting but the IT team
were really brilliant and that member
went in quite regularly to speak to it
find out how to use them and is now
quite proficient and I'm quite proud
that member who
I thank
you
okay just just quick confirm that
there's the obviously the response means
that no consultant TR so far been
commission to work on the leveling up
partnership thank you the last one
Bron thank you
chair
um no representations have been made why
not have to make a resolution no you
don't we've got a leader we've got uh
various counselors here who've got an
interest in these things so um we should
have made some
representation you'll notice um we did
manage to get down on our iPad here
you've got tonight you should have got
an email Pharmacy business it comes
under at 23 minutes past 4 read it it
talks about how pharmacies are asked by
the government to you know prop up the
Health Service like Matt and at the same
time they're closing like that they talk
about Norfolk uh actually losing six
including their boots as well so
um it's got Andrea lson is the is the uh
Minister responsible so we should we
should and I ask again should be uh
writing to her and saying this is a
serious problem because of the
underlying problem like dentists is
because the core money from central
government isn't enough for the
pharmacies to operate to do the all the
things they are expected to do now like
injections etc etc advising you when you
should go and see an Undertaker because
you're that bad okay so uh supplementary
second ask yeah thank
you yeah item 18 there are no petitions
so we can on do item number
19 um GRE is of motion and
here now coming up to the three hours
clearly we're not going to finish this
in five minutes so um I propose from the
chair that
weend our
meeting all the time by counc James all
in favor please
show is there extra allance to go with
thison know I do believe you me I
do
against
right so we've got three Nots as the
motion pron haes
Andy so you've each got three minutes up
to three minutes you don't have to take
the three
minutes please be brief to the
point we for for a proposal sorry for
second so the first one is Bron Annie
Bron thank you chair right I hope this
won't be at all contentious um thanks to
our head of Legal Services we had a very
good training session from Beth Evans
about counselor standards I think it's
probably routine when you get a new
Council um and that was a very
interesting and thoughtful presentation
um but when I spoke to her afterwards at
the end of it she was quite surprised
that we don't actually have the um
LGA model Council
um code conduct um and uh you know this
is a a situation where everybody would
be protected if we did have the LGA
local government associations modeled
Council of code of conduct it protects
counselors it protects the public and it
protects our staff as well our the
people at work public because it's a
very comprehensive and understanding
code of conduct at the moment when I
asked for the code conduct we got the
financial um uh regulations and the
prejudicial interests but all the rest
the rest of it that's on the moral code
of conduct wasn't there and that's
because I'm informed that we haven't
adopted a that particular code of
conduct we haven't adopted a full code
of conduct um the code of conduct of the
LGA covers General Behavior bullying and
harassment
discrimination confidentiality obtaining
consent and facilitating the Public's
right to legitimate information and it
obviously incorporates the N principles
of selflessness Integrity objectivity
accountability openness honesty and
Leadership and as um torich has suffered
a few hiccups in the recent past um
about coping with some of these issues
um I do think it's it would be very
fortunate for us if we adopted this code
of conduct it's a real Safeguard and it
means that most of the situations that
we can envisage and the contingencies
that might occur would be covered by a
clear code of conduct which most
councils in this country at local
Authority level do have adopted it would
make us all much safer
much more reliable and much more able to
cope with our job if any problems arose
and we are all human we all make
mistakes and so you know I do feel that
we should adopt the LGA full um
counselor's code of conduct um I'd just
like to finish off by if I can R near
Christmas time poting the prophet Isaiah
who said if you don't have I'm
summarizing here but if you don't have
have a set of standards and a basis on
which to make your decisions and you
claim Integrity you're just putting on a
filthy
coat thank you CC I believe that he's
going to the next standards committee
for
consideration thank you
so
sorry say exactly the same thing it's on
the agenda for the next meeting I wble
on about it the code of some time ago
has worked really well it's very similar
to the LGA code conduct but it is on the
agenda we'll discuss it there thank you
very much do I need a second you do
indeed oh well
second
for the fact that it's going to the the
standards committee for consideration um
coun Brenton but it will be debated
presely that committee takes on board
what you're saying they will be they
will report back at the next meeting
once those minutes are adop so I don't
need you
don't
okay the next motion is EV
HS
minutes in the 2019 forage Council has
decided to ban fireworks at Brun War
comp for Town Council resolved not to
fund Firework and to restrict that
levels both decisions came after a
petition of around 8,000 signatures
calling for a ban due to the rful effect
of exploding fireworks on starlings
roosting on bord Long Bridge and other
birds in the vicinity recently there
have been calls on social media to let
off fireworks at brunworth war or at
other possible sites at Easter water
near near to Long Bridge on New Year's
Eve although I gather permission has now
been refused at Brun wall for which I
give thanks however calls are still
continuing on social media to have
fireworks by the river at EAS of water
as our Council no longer owns Bron War
so cannot apply the 20 2019 decision I'm
therefore proposing to we register our
strong opposition to proposals to use of
fireworks in the vicinity of the bridge
where they lead to the death and injury
of Starlings and other birds may I
remind you that this Council has
committed to the biosphere natural
recovery pledge and has also declared a
climate emergency part of which
recognizes the disastrous decline of
wildlife in in the UK and Mr Durrant if
you remember his address the beginning
of this meeting movingly related to you
his personal experience of wildlife
decline which includes starlings which
are now on the national endangered list
in further support of my resolution I
refer to a recent rspca communication
about fireworks on us Eve citing the
results of a national survey finding
that over half of respondents Express
concern about the effects of fireworks
on wildlife and on pet animals when the
fireworks used to be left off in B the
New Year the starings rooting under the
bridge and other birds would scatter in
fear leading leading to many being
injured or dying due to hitting crash
barriers a road and buildings or dring
in the river I expect you've witnessed
or seen on television the amazing
Starling memor murmurations and I hope
that the very chatter and mimicry of
these wonderful bir sadly the number of
Starlings gathering at DUS by the bridge
has depleted considerably over the years
following the national Trend may I
therefore urge you as counselors to
fulfill our commitment Wildlife by
voting my
resolution thank you I a second
second
second uh all those in support of
council H's motion he
sh and
against
extensions
yeah
1643 again non extensions motion is
clearly carried very grateful thank you
I would just like add C hes
um from T's point of view when when this
matter first came up and Mr Durant gave
his his
um the the previous year and the
following year I specifically asked our
um cleansing team to give me the numbers
of any starings that were injured or
particularly dead but they came across
in their early morning clean up after
New Year's Eve who
wasn't that goes against the witnesses
told
me your motion is clear thank you very
much uh so the third notice of motion
was from
cigy yeah thank you very much given the
shortness of time available thought I'm
gonna forgo my speech and just read the
words of the link sentor users who was
also one of my residents who W was uh
unable to participate
today um my mental and emotional health
has been declining since the beginning
of the year I've tried along with my
doctor to try and stabilized without the
need of extra medication unfortunately I
had had to put up the extra medication
the three consultations that Devon
County Council have been running have
taken their toll on the service users
mental health and this last on
consultation has really been challenging
for everyone however it has been
particularly detrimental effect on me
I've been unable to even read through
the consultation let alone respond to it
which has significantly increased my
anxiety stress this coupled with an
extremely traumatic event on Saturday
led to an over overwhelmingly emotional
and triggering response on Monday my
mental state resulted in me being taken
by ambulance to AE I've just become yet
another statistic in the torage area to
attend Hospital how many more people is
it going to take before someone listens
and helps us the link centers are my
safety net the staff are excellent at
deescalation and preventing a service
user going into crisis I have had
several onet to ones over the last six
to eight months and and and I would have
been lost without them I use the link
center three times a week however
however I've been deliberately not going
for a few weeks to see if I'm able to do
without it it seems not thank you one
second I do thank you I'd just like to
than second counselor Craig's noce
motion um I was at the meeting with John
mckinness and so with he it's clear that
de County Council hasn't any idea what
they're going to replace the V centers
with they couldn't bring up any answer
to the questions about what the budget
was um and where they're going to place
these services and it's ironic that the
government's bringing in regulations to
ensure that Banks can't withdraw from
communities and I understand how
important that is and I'm totally in
favor of that until they can come up
with other kinds of financial support
for those and yet 's no such safeguard
for this service which is so important
and I can't believe there's any cheaper
support and service for people who need
that support from the link centers than
the one we've got at the moment I cannot
believe and I'm sure councelor wha who's
been working in volun sector for a long
time and I know from my experience that
actually it often isn't cheaper to do it
through the voluntary sector no way
because they can't can't be providing
all the adequacies that needed and so
you have to get consultants in and
Professionals in to support them so I do
really think that this is a very very
important issue and I second counc thank
you for that I always going to second
that myself I'm glad you did so all in
favor of gre's motion all the support
please
show I think that sends a very important
message that it was a unanimous
decision that brings us to the end of
the
meeting